hi i'm ray dalio the founder of
bridgewater in a new company principles
that's meant to pass along the
principles and tools that help me
succeed
i'm excited to share with you the dot
collector to use in your zoom meetings
it's a tool that i built for myself
because i wanted to know in my meetings
what everyone was thinking not just
those who were talking
how many times are you in a meeting
wondering what are others thinking
how do i give feedback without
interrupting can we save the learning
from this meeting to use later and share
with others
while i love zoom meetings it drives me
crazy that i'm missing all of this
information
so i asked my team to build the dot
collector to use on
zoom here's how it works if you want to
give someone feedback or tell them what
you think
simply select the attribute rate it and
write them a note
they will do the same with you it's like
giving 360
degree feedback in real time all of the
dots
are automatically saved and summarized
in a grid
so it's easy to see the highlights or
drill down
into whatever anyone is thinking it even
produces
automatic summaries of the meeting for
those who want to see it later
over time this data paints rich pictures
of people and their performance
which is invaluable for helping people
and their teams improve
it's great for reviews too i urge you to
start collecting dots
zoom is now the place to do it